[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh listeners know chin almost died last
week
yeah the joke episode yeah
i would look over it would make jokes
i'd look over jim's like this
he just hunched over that cove hit him
hard yeah
no it was excruciating you know it was
an appendix
uh not my life but freaking probably up
there
you know when things are weird though
like it's a feeling you haven't really
felt before
exactly so i knew something was wrong
yeah like i would not go to the
emergency room if i felt like it you
don't seem like the type of person
that's just going to no doctor i was
like wait until i
i'm almost dying where i'm at yeah oh i
just knew something was wrong i feel
like you could take pain easily
i could take pain it's not that was just
but that was like
insane like i i normally wouldn't be
doing that stuff in front of you guys
how was it literally literally the whole
episode he's like this yeah yeah
but but could you take it could you take
a you know
what's up could you could you do number
two a [ __ ]
yeah don't know so that's another
problem
you know yeah you can just say what are
you
doing
you're not taking care of kids at
daycare and you're just about to
i know right yeah can you go duty
so that i guess after your surgery
they're supposed to like check to see if
you can even pee
right away because that's a sign like
something's wrong if you can't pee so
they're just wiggling your dick
no i wiggled it
i thought there's no in between with you
you got to do number two
wiggle your dick me in the middle yeah
the constipation was legit
right i didn't poo for like poo i didn't
poop for like a day
yeah they gave me like a lace wait after
this
yeah i'll do it and when it comes out it
is a
roaring it's an avalanche of what is
this thing called
no what the they gave you coal lace it's
a stool
softener donkey yeah and his blood gates
open
it's like splash mountain it works oh
man it is amazing you wanna take it
yeah i tell you number one it sounds
like that's one of them you just gotta
take all your clothes off for oh yeah
yeah i'm gonna be here for you go to the
shower
i'll be here for a minute immediately
after yeah shower your leg fall asleep
like
this chin's older too i was worried
about you i'm like [ __ ]
man you guys are great so thank you all
very much i tried to send you boba
sue friends like hey man just get any
postmates i got you i'm like
it's cool thank you man yeah plus you
can't really eat because you
your stomach is like it's like this no
that's how i figure you could
even even before you couldn't even after
because you know when they do the
surgery
or something into you oh i figured boba
would be nice that was
sounding nice but i was going to have
yeah how are your bowel movements now
uh they're back to sort of normal but
not 100 normally yeah it's gonna take a
while yeah take a little was your girl
with you the whole time
she was in san francisco yeah she
planned the trip
for a while now so like like uh
girlfriend's trip
yeah and it was cuddling cuddle bottle
they probably cut well did did
did she leave before you were before
yeah she couldn't fly
she didn't come back huh she thought
about coming back but then she's like
but i mean it's not like
life-threatening surgery if you if i was
yeah
talking about yes you under the knife my
girl was going on there
cause you have no way okay no wait wait
i get what he's saying you probably just
gave her a lot of information that you
were okay
yeah cause i'm not i can walk i can do
whatever i need to do but it's like it's
not like open hearts
you're right yeah you're right yeah if i
was in a wheelchair and i need help then
i get it but
this is just yeah you want you walked
right out of that [ __ ]
well yeah it's not so scary on your own
wait so how'd you get home
my brother or brother your brother hell
yeah he came up he came up from orange
county
no he lives in santa monica luckily all
right he moved here
he moved forward does he still have
godzilla he does have godzilla oh [ __ ]
what did we pick you up in that
yeah what's godzilla what's garcia
i don't think i'm badass right myself
the only
japanese car i like i like datsun
oh that's what your brother rolling with
yeah
i saw it on fast and furious yep he's
running fast and furious healthy
is what he got no he has an older one
but he looks just like still
yeah they're black they are monsters
damn they're super
fast dude they named godzilla faster
than the porsche no
[Music]
it's all wheel drive though so it's just
like as launch control they're
well you guys didn't miss too much in
cleveland cleveland would
listen everyone the media makes it seem
like la we're the worst we're locked
down
we're north korea blah blah blah
cleveland
it was it was like i am wretched but
just the four of us
it was there was there's no one besides
the show we see people at shows
and other than that downtown was dead
uber even when we were uber
you waited 40 50 minutes like when we
were uh during the day like on a
saturday
during the day just dead damn we were
just that like no one around
[ __ ] even in uber i'm glad you said yeah
they was like yo you wait 40 minutes and
if they see you
they're canceling you like now we good
yeah we literally had to wait so long
for ubers and lifts
just to get canceled why why is it still
dead oh it's just code
code and also the money the money a lot
of people went to door dash because it
was locked down and it wasn't making a
lot of money we're talking about uber
but that's not why
i would be dead um no no no no he's
talking about that dude that was telling
us
he was saying that because this is in
every city though
in the pandemic people aren't going the
grocery store they're using post mates
and uber eats
yeah so not too many people taking rides
so most most people are doing postmates
instead of uber now yeah so they weren't
yeah they weren't doing like the actual
oops that's everywhere
but we've most of the cities we've gone
and ubers have been [ __ ] hey
not a lot of people are doing it tampa
besides la
like most of the cities are bad texas
was fine
texas yeah texas but i think ohio never
really shut down
they like left it up to them to decide
oh really they had a curse what it is
yeah they had a curse
it's cool though and like no one's like
crazy but it's just not
like la's ten times more busy like oh
wonder
you walk down the street right out here
off santa monica boulevard i mean it's
bad i i've never
yeah have you have you done hilarities
before yeah that street it's off uh
it's usually buzzed yeah buzzing
but it was yeah i think yeah out of all
the cities we've gone to
during this whole pandemic that's
probably like the most like and they
were they were on it too like when we
you know jay was saying when he sells
merch you know jace had coveted
you know yeah if they asked them where
master wearing masks we selling
merch there's the only one like you have
to leave a mask only sell merch
yeah that was on the club yeah first
they're just on it
they don't get shut down because they're
practically considered a restaurant so
they never had to shut down i guess
oh that makes sense yeah cleveland was
dope though it was
i love those are great yeah i love it i
like i like being in that like the
suburbs of cleveland [ __ ] hotels
airbnb's the movie yeah yep
our airbnb was dope i liked it for my b
day yeah who's birthday who's birthday
who's birthday
spokane birthday yeah yeah
dude yeah cleveland yeah we didn't even
do much i mean we worked out that yeah
we worked on that cleveland fit was dope
and watched to catch a sm a lot
of to catch a smuggler yes that's kind
of smugglers have you all seen that yeah
i seen it mm-hmm you ever seen the
ketchup
smuggler have you seen it before this
weekend though
me neither i always thought it looked
stupid as [ __ ]
it does and then jay jay was like man
you guys gotta watch catch smuggling
like man let me see this [ __ ]
we were addicted oh yeah i watched it
last night when i got home oh you did
yeah i watched american idol listen if
you can watch american island not cry
you're a goddamn
satan worshiper it is it's so
heartbreaking
they know how to get them stories that
dude got on my nerves they all get on my
nerves i feel like it'd be pretty easy
to get past them because everyone no
one's story lines up
yeah yeah but it is but like think about
it like if someone's just asking you
questions and you just went
right on the spot and you just went on a
regular trip you're like what the
yeah but that's where they [ __ ] that i
do like yeah but that's where they [ __ ]
up because they'll be like oh what were
we doing venezuela
she's like you know visit my friend like
where's your friend
live she's like what like where's your
friend there's like oh i
uh i don't know you don't know what city
you're friendly like no
and then like oh what did you do there
she's like oh man
i don't know he's like you don't know
what you did he's like let me see your
thing and
it shows that she was like all over the
[ __ ] country he's like what are we
doing all around here she's like
just driving like you [ __ ] oh yeah no
yes and then he'll be like let me see
your [ __ ] land
cocaine all up in her [ __ ] oh you're
talking about different ones in general
god i got it some some were [ __ ] up
but a lot of times it's just regular
probably like that one that uh oh with
the freaky [ __ ] with the freaky [ __ ]
the dude the yeah bro i didn't trust him
either but he just went down there to
[ __ ]
down there to [ __ ] do some weird [ __ ]
like the ball gagging stuff in his
and yeah the p the p [ __ ]
what was that thing he had a wilderness
health achievement
wet works put down some people yeah
he had that he had the ball gag and then
they're like if we look because he did
look like a pedophile but he did
sucks to accuse him of that like are we
gonna fight they literally took his
laptop i was like what's your pass code
he had to give it to him which i think
is some
sort of private issue but you know if
they're going to push
you know you could just wait i want my
[ __ ] lawyer but whatever so the guy
gives him the password
and they're going through all his
pictures like are we going to find
pictures of kids they went through his
phone
he's like no like are you sure and then
the guy's like
yeah there's some badass [ __ ] man all
right
there's exactly what it is he's out
there he's just out there [ __ ] weird
dude old white guys
go to venezuela to [ __ ] the hottest
girls in the world for
10 cents a person is that what it owes
it's around 10 cents
that's around 10 cents i made that up
for probably ten dollars
how many costa rica i mean listen
how else is that dude how is he's gonna
get it you see all you saw how ugly he
[ __ ] but
okay but that's one thing but then they
had these things where you see like uh
in the back they had like these big
antiques or
or like where you have your suitcases oh
people they're like yo if they have any
kind of suspicion of
drugs being smuggled in like an antique
they like knock on it yeah
there's like big wooden elephant from
africa they're awful
there's something going on in there this
is someone's artwork they made a
thousand dollars for
you see a guy with chainsaws like
they're looking like
nah nothing wow that's cool and then you
get like a messed up antique
what it got to be because they set you
up to believe that there's possibilities
they're like yeah you know when you see
stuff you know see this type of thing on
on a piece like this it means they're
probably they break a bunch of laws
man i feel i feel like they're breaking
a bunch of laws where
if they'd ask me like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about yeah i want a lawyer
how about that
how would you suck my dick oh what about
and they were finding food and [ __ ]
what was it like dry fish yeah clams and
chicken [ __ ]
it's they yeah it's not good also the
drug business
dude they're what what the people
they're busting i guess we have to have
it i think we should legalize drugs
but i guess we have to have it but you
know they're catching
grains of sand at the beach because
it's absolutely a multi multi multi
billion dollar industry
america's the number one consumer of
drugs so think about that
oh yeah so it's like oh you stopped one
little package you know how much
shit's getting through at the loading
docks and [ __ ] haven't you ever seen a
wire season two
dude they kept agreeing uh at the end of
every episode you know
we're just glad we you know got this
person off the streets you know we're
making the streets safer and it's like
there's so many
they are like they're like vigilantes
tsa they go too hard
oh they they were going hard and the
medals even like if you were regular
guys i wouldn't hear you talking about
tsa
security but think about it if you were
just getting questions you just went on
a regular ass trip
it's gonna make you think like what the
[ __ ] did i do like am i okay you know
especially when they're grilling
yeah now if you've ever gone to like
toronto or vancouver
they're they're listening yeah i've been
to canada but i'm not
i'm here for business like what i have a
show what theater you tell them what
hotel there
all right see ya it's where when like
what are you here for
i don't know
cartoon character yeah i don't know why
people freak the [ __ ] out it's like
just tell them where you're going people
get nervous talking to like i don't know
they get nervous talking to like
that's why we gotta [ __ ] search your
ass yeah true
man they stopped that one girl with that
fat ass oh yeah he's a weirdo
right he just wanted to talk girl what
you doing what you doing here huh
you got
she goes up 36 now so that was you know
whatever but then he was like
you know we just found out yeah she you
know has has a charge for money
laundered
man we got something you got something
going on in that question no one else
watches american island here
no not since like years ago you don't
chin you like music
this season the town is [ __ ] stupid
how good people are you gonna vote
that's like i never about i've never
voted you just like to watch it yeah i
just checked it out
yeah i just watched those like like
there was a homeless lady like a dime
piece mom with a little baby
and she was like yeah i'm homeless right
now like hopefully i can make it here
at least those stories always [ __ ]
give me oh dude i'll cry my life
[ __ ] i'll cry sunday nights you know
what the last three sundays i've cried
with myself it shows uh the x factor
uh all those [ __ ] shows when they
bring out those stories oh
dude american idol really knows how to
tug at your heartstrings
this one girl has some uh like serious
disease
and she's like yeah they predict i'm
willing to live to 36. and she got big
like her sister recorded on tick-tock
singing from her like hospital to bed
and she can
[ __ ] sing and her sister goes uh hey
this is my sister singing from the
hospital bed
if she gets however many yeses shot this
from american idol
and so she got a ton of yeses so she got
this for american idol
dude she can sing damn it's crazy
and then there's then there's another
dude there's this big dude whose
father passed away next to him in bed
when he was six and his brother has
um his brother's on the spectrum he has
like the mentality of a nine-year-old
it's heartbreaking and his his brother
kept asking where like every time it's
father's day or his birthday where his
dad's at
and he's like 27 now oh [ __ ] so he wrote
a song about his brother and
trying to cry on this [ __ ] show i'm
telling like god
i am american bro and they can sing
the big guy with the brother with autism
and dad passed away he could sing but
he's only 18
and they're like man we want to pass you
but we're going to do you a favor by
telling you to come back in two years
because you need more work
we don't want to ruin this for you yeah
go do gigs around town
and then come here in two years and it's
gonna be a much better time hopefully he
[ __ ] sticks with it
all the stories man dude the stories are
nuts there was one that just a
dude got um he was a baby and got
his family got blown up in a bomb and
he's surviving it but he's
you know got no this american idol no it
was uh i think x factor
x factor one of those shows and uh he
went out there and sang imagine
by uh [ __ ] john lennon dude there's
some of them
dude when they say when they say their
stories i look at my girl my god i hope
they can sing
dear god when they do doesn't it [ __ ]
you up
mind-blowing dude when they can it's the
only thing that has been emotional
so weird oh my god i hope they [ __ ]
make it
yeah it's fun or like the homeless lady
like she
she was a mom and her this is her dad
yeah her dad came her dad's homeless
she's homeless she has a little kid
the other her baby daddy just dipped out
on her
and she uh i was i was telling my girl
i'm like
man if you're uh katy perry she has like
50 million dollars
i just don't see how you just don't be
like hey where you live i'm gonna buy a
house
if you have a kid i have 50 million
dollars
i guess my girls like where you do that
opens up the floodgates for other people
i'm like
all right it's one time deal you know i
don't know
you're invested oh i mean it was a show
also like that uh when you write your
songs and they had uh
like uh john legend uh i should gay the
police
no no not the voices
and he helps you write your songs and
[ __ ] it is oh yeah yeah because
shit's weak song land
what's song land yeah it's online song
yeah yeah
it sounds
[Applause]
it was a big deal yeah i guess you can't
do it yeah you can't you can't do
too many of those shows because what's
crazy is the american idol they go what
song you're singing they're like oh this
is my original song wrote produce myself
and they're like 15 or 16 and even
like lionel richie's like i mean you're
ridiculous
yeah like you're 16. who are the judges
the judges are katy perry lionel richie
and luke bryant
they're great oh luke bryan the the
country star i like that guy
yeah yeah he's dope i thought that was
chris red
damn that's crazy i i auditioned for agt
like a couple years ago really yeah
trying to be that clean mainstream
i was like man this ain't for me did you
really yeah
i didn't have like the i didn't have
like the minute you were on the tv not
on the tv
you know did you not pass that but i was
no dude
i'm glad i did it it was a pasadena it
was such a blessing that i didn't yeah
yeah
is that because i was like bro this is
weird and like they didn't even care
about my jokes
you know it was did you do the two they
want your story yeah yeah
but like but like the thing with these
shows is like
like i'm not sad about my story you know
some people are still going through i'm
not saying these people
you know like i'm not you don't you
don't lean into the story yeah i'm just
different where i'm at with my story is
just like i'm not sad
yeah i'm not like those are the cards
you're dealt and you power yeah i
powered through it you know but like
i get you know these other people
they're able to lean into it because
they
you know probably still feeling it
probably still going through it probably
you know still working through those
emotions
but me it's just different so like i
felt uncomfortable and
i'm so glad i didn't because i remember
when my uh
uh my manager called me and told me i
didn't make it
on agt i was like [ __ ] yes and then
literally that same night
was when uh cause i just had met rogan
and he hit me up he was like hey man
i want you to come do rogan and friends
that's cool so it was like
this is it see ya yeah it was like see
i'm never doing this the big bang
upstairs
yeah yeah the same for you yeah right it
was it was weird
for you like american idol like
obviously gives you like a
fan base but it's tricky because then
you're under their contract
it's like the ultimate fighter it's like
it's much better to get on the ultimate
not do the ultimate fire make the ufc
the right the regular way than the
ultimate fighter because you get an
ultimate fighter
you're tied in these long contracts
you're not getting paid well
yeah so same thing with american idol
like they own all your [ __ ] dude
like carrie underwood didn't start make
money until she got out of that contract
dude i wonder how [ __ ] long that
contract is oh it's a
beast really yeah they tie you up
you know only a couple of people like
that uh
that have won it have actually like
popped yeah jim kelly
kelly kelly clarkson jenner has made for
different reasons though but yeah kelly
clarkson
carried under did jennifer hudson win no
she got 10. she got oh she had 10. she
had 10.
really about
she's from arizona yep yeah jordan
sparks still killing it yeah
yeah she stays straight uh she's more so
a mom now she concentrates more so on
her family yeah the show coming up
she got a tv show coming out she had
that song one step
at a time oh no
oh yeah no air with chris brown scotty
mccrary had a big
uh splash in country music but most of
them don't do well like tyler taylor
hicks is changing tires
what about that one guy uh davis moore
david cook works at uh [ __ ]
it was a mormon guy mormon david
archuleta
oh dave archuleta had that one really
big song crush
that's all he had did he win uh i
believe
he won he did like a short episode on
hannah montana
and then i haven't really i don't want
that yeah that guy oh yeah i'm really
kidding you know that kid
yeah he was really good he was the
runner up yeah runner up got him
jesus chris look at me fans he had dude
over 97 million people voted
what the [ __ ] but he didn't win now he
was right
he was a runner-up yeah again so who
beat him
but it's weird because they get done in
you know 96 because obviously 97 million
people didn't buy a
single otherwise he'd be yeah i wonder
why i wonder if it's just like oh they
only like you for this
you know what i mean they don't really
get something they don't send other [ __ ]
yeah
i mean i get it carrie underwood you
know what i mean undeniable undeniable
yeah sunday
clarkson jennifer hudson like you you
get it but like some people i wonder if
it's just like oh i just like you
here on this like i don't give a [ __ ]
about your music after that
i wonder if that's the case well does it
go with like i like your story more than
your talent
that uh that could be a thing too is
that him singing there too i think so
let's see
yeah he better still kill it request it
a lot
what you think chin i can tell he's
really good
you're just he's singing over at other
songs so it's a little it's good
i'll rather him do like an instrumental
thing but you see his his roles yeah
yeah up and down that's good
you never wanted to audition for
anything like that i did audition oh you
didn't audition for it star
search oh [ __ ] oh geez not the first one
oh
okay they did they did a comeback i knew
as soon as i said i knew him
[Applause]
but you didn't make star search justin
timberlake
self sabotage that's what i did i was so
i was so cocky and overconfident about
my singing at the time
i came in i partied with my friends the
night before oh wow
i was still drunk when i showed up to
the auditions oh [ __ ] and i just forgot
my lyrics
and then i'm like so they have a red
light on the camera right yeah they tell
you ahead of time like
millions millions of people are
potentially gonna watch this right so
just make sure you do you well
so i'm just looking at the camera and
it's red and i'm like i forgot
everything and then i'm thinking like oh
[ __ ] they're going to play this like
they do american idol all the
[ __ ] ups oh yeah you'd be the [ __ ]
luckily they didn't
make it that was good
some sort of documentation of that i
know no it's out there somewhere if
someone has it in the star search chin's
all
no just singing
i had a couple words coming out you
start at any moment now
i had a couple words come out i think
it's like what song what did you say
it was an usher or drew hill nice and
slow something like tell me what you
want
you can't remember i can't remember that
how old were you at the time
um mid-20s you lit like a swamp yeah
you've been cocky mid-20s
yeah oh my god
good learning lesson did you call your
parents you're like yeah it [ __ ] up
my parents have no idea what i'm back
home to the family and [ __ ]
no i bet you just talking cash [ __ ]
before they end yeah yeah yeah
star surgery different after this oh
this [ __ ] sure yeah i saw all the other
contestants
all the other auditions and i'm like i'm
like dude i got this
after hearing everyone's scene and i
came up and i'm like sorry
see the red light and then i'm like i
forget my layers i'm like [ __ ] which is
so weird because
you would definitely learn from it
because now you're like over yeah yeah
yeah
over like what's up like you're a little
worried right now like you're super
prepared
i am but that's for a producer that's
probably one of the better things you
wanna yeah yeah just be constantly
looking at it like ah
that moment prepared you for right now
i'm serious i think everything prepares
you for what you do
damn and you know who was the host back
then
i don't remember let me see the reboot
of star street you know my manager
uh is ed mcmahon's son lex mcmahon oh
yeah
oh hell yeah
star certainly star search was big dude
they found so many people
uh bo weaver and sam riddle okay i don't
know
no that's that's uh narrated so it was
arsenio hall maybe
yeah so mark i think it was arsenio yeah
yeah i think it was arsenal
man that's he's oh he's alleged did you
get to meet him
no no oh how are you doing i mean
yeah oh you know who was on our flight
to cleveland michael blackson oh yeah
michael blackson
yeah no i just remember
stevie telling me uh that michael
blackson was on the flight and told me
he was wearing like some
ridiculous like neon i thought he looked
fly it was floppy he had a mask i was
like god damn that guy looks cool
then he took his mask off i was like
that looks like michael blackson sure
enough
like that's definitely michael blackson
it was like he had like this
grinch neon green
right almost like a mink yeah sick like
he just
came down to like what his knees like
because him and joe coy are close i'm
like yo michael black's on my flight
he's like make sure you say hi and tell
him i say hi
i was like is he nice though he's like
yeah he's the best i was like i don't
want to say anything
and then when we got there we went for
our bag i was like dude cleveland man
he's like shows what you doing i was
like shows
and then we just started talking he's
such a nice guy he's cool
he didn't come on the podcast oh what
awesome he's so funny
i hope that happens yeah he's great he
got away with him and joe
at the same time yeah he know each other
so well yeah he got to wear that outfit
oh it was spicy yeah i i like i liked it
i texted the group i was like where did
you even find that at
i like kid you said it was yeah it was
good she had blue jeans with neon
stripe down the center of this the shoes
even made my shoes were white with neon
i know kicks i've never seen that out
i've never seen those kicks yeah
but the i like to kick the designer down
i wonder if he's here this is him in
cleveland no it's just his instagram
no that's him yeah the second he does
mean great
this one nah nah right underneath it
this one yeah that one
he's dancing on people look at him
damn he wearing a suit
oh he looks like he's having fun oh
having the best time
he said i'll take him 18 to 80. dumb
crippled or crazy
like that where do you get that outfit
he probably has some custom made to be
honest yeah yeah i would assume
even his suitcase was a designer go go
to the way everybody go to the one where
he's pouring champagne is that him
backstage
yeah his his security guard was dressed
like he just started his own podcast
yep coming to america oh okay oh is he
in come
to america yeah he's good he's there
he's uh he's so
great man look at that jacket
yeah dude he had a yeah it was so it was
something like that
yeah look at this character like those
kicks look like what are those they look
like new balances yeah
i don't know i've never seen them and i
know shoes but man is that him with jlo
up top there
i thought it was too but i don't think
it is anymore who what daddy
oh cap it is yeah it is or is that a
look-alike what the hell i hope
that's gotta be a look-alike who wait
who's that's jake you can't tell
that's her that's true that's what he's
saying i'm not the reason they broke up
because her and a-rod supposedly broke
up
not supposedly they did not get it
there's a report
it was reportedly walking through it
news be tripping she's so bad
yeah is that jayla it kind of looks a
little off yeah i feel like the first
one
in the video man i don't know but
when you refresh it i don't
no yeah yeah i think that's j lo bruh
[Music]
in the beginning but then afterwards it
didn't look like her yeah after after a
while does not look like her she's so
bad
who's this though yeah because he
started his own podcast oh my god you're
that guy from coming to america
oh my god no i'm not even mercy oh
that's an actress
yeah oh yeah she's an actor she's bad
too oh he always has to stay with him i
said dumbass nobody thinks everyone
didn't come to america too
his videos he's in a movie with uh got a
movie coming out with jamie foxx yeah oh
yeah yeah talk about on
netflix yeah he has his his own podcast
coming out soon
oh you gotta buy a sucker with michael
blackson what a sucker
he's with his best friend asian guy
right yeah yeah who's the one that
what's up
what's up chin sweetie everything like
babies
and i needed some titties in the house
let's get back in for i mean natalia
podcasts are lit already
that's titty number one social media is
influential
that was it right oh that's my homie
from family matters that's my
seriousness
yeah wow he looked older right
you know that right he's a singer too
he's actually a really good
he's actually a really good singer yeah
he's a real good singer
really yeah i didn't know that yeah he
used to sing all the time on family
matters
if y'all watched it again you know that
yeah
anybody watched the uh what was the
oscars the
grammys last time oh yeah grammys i feel
like it's so outdated
like i think they they should just stop
the award shows and just announce who
the winners are
and then maybe do like a festival or
some [ __ ] because all i want to see the
performances but
you know having a host it's just it's
just so it seems so outdated
man i don't watch those in years i used
to love them love them i never missed
any of them
i used to work them for eve grammys
oscars golden globes i worked them for
years
but they just seemed so outdated man oh
didn't you see beyonce on the carpet or
something oh yeah
did i ever daddy saw her i saw
uh i mean you name it did you see margot
robbie at one of those
i mean margot robbie wolf of wall street
harley quinn from
harley suicide yeah dude i was meeting
her waiting for an uber
you know i'm pretty confident around
women dude i was like
it was like it was like to catch a
smuggler and i had cocaine in my bag
so where are you going like nowhere no
no what was that movie she did with will
smith
no that's usually that's charlie's there
i know you're talking no she didn't move
your will smith
oh wait it was what were they like on
people out of the con artist yeah
yeah dude she was smoke dude you know
who
smoked show in person it's paris hilton
and i don't like skinny girls really you
saw that documentary
she was rebecca i was like oh my she was
so pretty you know what i actually
haven't seen a picture of a video
perishing in
years i haven't either and then i saw
like sort of get out of her uber because
i was waiting
after i think it was going globe she was
there she gets out and she's walking up
my god
god who is that yeah and she got close
i'm like oh [ __ ] that's paris hilton
she was so pretty man she's a dj now wow
she's a dj yeah
would she have a is this a podcast yeah
she recently started a podcast
who doesn't have one i know right yeah
uh her documentary is kind of great
because she's always on her phone
and she was in a relationship with this
guy and also she dj's as well
and uh he just didn't he was like a
london guy like an [ __ ]
and before her biggest performances like
a festival of my life they got into it
and they broke up with her
and she's like man you always do this
and she's like this is why i'm always on
my phone
because you don't get me people don't
get like how she
makes money it's on her phone yeah and
she's like breaks down so
she's like but now she's married now so
good for her yeah she's she's definitely
smart
she knows what she's doing for you know
she's smart she has so many videos she's
she's the one who put uh nicole richie
on she's the one who could
kardashian kim kardashian designer
assistant yeah and and she would bring
kim with her to red carpet
and that's when all the black dudes like
who the [ __ ] is that
and then ray j
closet she doesn't wear the same thing
uh twice right her clothes
elliott that's just that's just that's
that justin elliott i'm talking about
like change
jury nothing the jeweler and stuff they
give to her and then they take back they
said
a lot a lot of people julie if it's like
real like millions of dollars they don't
buy it they just give it to him
like anything you see people at the
award shows they don't own that oh
they're just weird
no like gucci or who dior whatever kind
of like promotion
yeah they'll be like okay we're this
people ask you say you were in dior
and then they come two days later and
take your [ __ ] that's what happened with
me they give me the dopest outfits
and two day literally can i pay you for
that promo at least
no you just literally shook you up with
like 10 000 worth of dope [ __ ] and a
stylist and then they take it back i'll
take it i'll be like i'm wearing this
sweater no you can though because if
it's like custom fitted to your body
they'll be like you can keep that
because we can't fit down anybody else
but if it's like
shoes or yeah jewelry i would assume you
would have to get a lot of custom [ __ ]
yeah yeah he's just on my most more like
accessories
but to your point though uh because i
had to get so much custom stuff you
would like you can just keep it all my
outfits from
the oscars golden globes academy awards
the grammys damn i have like
dope ass outfits that i'll never wear
but yeah where you gonna wear it just
like joe bass suit oh so
yeah we're gonna wear it like crushed
velvet like dope [ __ ] really yeah
velvet dude we had a purple suit right
purple suit that's
that broke on you know when they do bro
cam
you know they do the slow cam that broke
you have that video it's on instagram
i think i posted i was like shout out to
the oscars remember when i worked oscars
and
ripped my suit yeah you they you on e
they have like the
i forget what it's called it's like the
fashion it is that slow they're like hey
yeah yeah they like rush over me like
hey they want you to do the fashion cam
like really
like yeah and i had to suit and i went
to go like this with it
like throw it open like look all dope
yeah and it [ __ ] ripped right down
the middle in the back
oh you can see my face i'm like oh how
much is that suit worth
i don't know is it still ripped to this
day
like somewhere in your closet that's it
right there
i love her was that the big girl yeah
no no no no she's she working look at
that outfit
done [ __ ] she does a lot of the videos
she did uh
i was on the show with her the black
girl yeah i was on that on that dating
filter with her [ __ ] what's her name she
hosts
all the love and hip-hop uh reunions i'm
having the time yeah she does
oh look at this right here that's your
suit uh one of them yeah
man that's just dope yeah let's cover
that song good song
damn would you work the oscars but you
basically see your point the grammys is
dead
uh but even the views are like way down
like way way down what's the uh after
this chick you see the views
uh for the moment because i remember the
only thing that reminded me about the
grammys was bill burr
what uh he had like a little uh i guess
he was tweeting about it or something
like that i said oh i forgot the grammys
was on last night
recording record low but uh but so the
grammys
the oscars the golden glo all of them
record
i mean but also like brian makes the
point all the time like can you name a
move like when you look at the oscars
like
i get they're trying to be woke how
about just the best actress the best
actor
the best movies win yeah [ __ ] your
narrative on woke and
chinese black white i don't give a [ __ ]
if all black people win just make the
best
movie best actors win don't do it
because you think that's what society
wants
yeah just have the best people win and
then people would [ __ ] pay attention
mm-hmm awards on measly 7.9 million
viewers
um record low
last year was 18 dude cut in half i
heard it was kind of weird too because
the only people who could go were
people who were nominated for the oscars
like socially distanced
people are giving harry uh styles a lot
of [ __ ]
he went up during dosha cat's
performance and he was like talking to a
bunch of people he was like making his
rounds
oh no oh no what are we gonna do
oh where do you think he tested negative
you think they would like
no they thought it was disrespectful
that he was doing it during her
performance oh not necessarily because
of kovitz
okay it's boring as [ __ ] man yeah it
spices the [ __ ] up well hold on don't
you look at that
[ __ ] she know she looked good too yeah
he going
she was shaking what does she look like
[Applause]
that's doshicat she's very cool i've
never known what she looked like
she got a new like video that's fire she
said
yeah she's screaming what's going on in
the streets yeah it's like kind of
underworldly but like
underworld was full of black vampires
everyone's hot as [ __ ] seems like such a
freak
oh yeah she's big she talks about how
she likes getting uh
stepped on sexually oh i'm into that
what the [ __ ] is that although i get a
size 13 girls
i'm like you asked for a girl
what's the [ __ ] safe word dog
john enchilada it's
too that's weird way you read that oh no
i saw an
interview she was doing because they
were talking about uh like some weird
like
secret king she was into she said that
she likes having her face stepped on
like with a shoe on or just barefoot i
would imagine barefoot
barefoot for sure barefoot she's so used
to dating like really scrawny awkward
white dudes
so like i don't know she's less pressure
i think her her face can handle like a
scrawny white
yeah it's not necessarily something
that's what changes kelly stepping on
her face she's good
yeah well i think ass jump on there i
know she did i don't know about back she
must be talking about white guys you
know black guys we keep our socks on
you do
is she a little freak huh
well she seems like a freak
yeah those award no one knows your time
out so i'm gonna carry on i do but the
listeners can't so no one's gonna get it
um yeah those awards are just strange
man
it's just beyonce once she's the most
winningest uh
female of all time i think now i think
any uh person
for the singing category as well but for
female i believe she's like the most
awarded
what about michael jackson michael
jackson no i think beyonce
took it they love her at the grammys
though but i mean like you said the best
let the best one win yeah and she put
out fire albums
i don't know yeah it's just i mean
george [ __ ] totally oh
you won't you you conduct you got you're
on there some right now like award shows
do we care about them like
the weekend is boycotting the grammys
you don't care about you seeing him
performing
i don't give a flying [ __ ] you you don't
care about them not the grammys i don't
give a [ __ ]
i liked him at the super bowl so if he
never performs on tv again i'll just
watch on youtube i don't give a [ __ ]
so the girl the grammys you don't care
about who's performing don't care
you just want to see who want to win no
i don't know because what is it what
does it mean to you
if they win what's up what's up never
giving a [ __ ] but like but the oscars
too it's like
i've never known i've never heard it
i've never watched oscar's grammy
all those all those award shows i've
never given up but also if you let the
public vote on what was the best movie
like avengers would win every year
yeah yeah and then they're wrong with
that that's what i'm saying
so it's like it's this weird group who
decides
what movie's the best the committee yeah
it's this weird [ __ ] committee
actually source awards 95. should you
watch that what about hip-hop wars
what i'm saying that one was funny to me
though oh but i get what you're saying
like let the people vote
okay and it's weird because like taylor
swift when she's like this this because
the fans like fans had nothing to do
with this
yeah they have no vote he just said he's
a committee he's like
it's like 12 people the the the
committee you know everyone
for a while was like oh well i guess
oscars they're in trouble because it's
all white committee
so that's why you see you know not that
their movies are bad but
a lot of the candidates are
asian-american or african-american
because they're like because like two
years ago it was like all white people
and then they're like oh let's look at
the committee and they're all white guys
that's a problem and the grammys they
had like one black guy because the week
the head
the head the guy who runs the thing is
black black that's what they were saying
in the weekend was like man it's all
it got to be racial they was like nah
it's a black guy up there but again
like it is weird but he also
acknowledged he's like we don't get it
right all the time
well that's why you [ __ ] idiot
shouldn't have this power though yeah
this should be half fan vote half of
you guys i guess like you're giving
these idiots too much power yeah
especially
who the [ __ ] that guy if you know what
he's doing he'd be singing why is he
critiquing everyone's yeah do you even
listen to this [ __ ] what's it say
it's like the same people like
you dead spin or whoever write articles
on uh a stand-up comic special
if they knew anything about comedy they
would be doing it
true so you're going to critique dave
chappelle or kevin hart what the [ __ ]
yeah who are you music and comedy
subjective
like this person might hate dave
chappelle's comedy
but the majority of people [ __ ] love
them and then yeah you dictate you yeah
yeah that's that is our music too like
dozier cat compared to beyonce you're
talking about apples and oranges
so how are you going to decide for right
this weird committee
yeah for ratings i think that you if you
want people to like pay attention
get people involved like you don't have
people like let me be a fan
like mtv music awards is all fan driven
i would imagine those are bigger than
this
oh yeah i used to watch those mtv music
organizations
and videos yeah those were actually
pretty [ __ ] good that's all fan
driven now now when
here's the problem when you do that bts
asians ride for theirs so bts won
every award possible but again oh they
did their ratings their ratings were up
there though yeah i know but the problem
is it's like is
his beat that's where it gets tricky
like is bts the best i think they're
great i love yeah but not the best
but they want to everybody i think if
you're in every category nationally yes
maybe
but but here's the promise like there's
so many asians right
well that's more asians than americans
true so if you're going to open up to
international voting which they do
bts can win every single award what's
like yao me
he was always the number one all-star
vote-getter because they opened up
voting to china
does that mean he's the best player was
it bees was he the best
kobe duck though bad yeah shaq used to
expose him
but i get what you said it's just weird
yeah it is i love beethoven's i think
you should win i thought the performance
last night
sucked they they performed they were off
man yeah they were off
dude we recorded mick and idol to watch
bts perform live because i love them
they were they were awesome what did you
watch
you said they were awful he was like no
you tell me because the one can sing and
they were singing dynamite
my son boston that's his favorite song
so i heard a thousand times a day
yeah and like you know how it should be
yeah i'm telling he was just off
when they get to the top of the building
they're off i've actually never seen a
performance i saw their tiny desks
they saw the tiny desk i've never seen
them like perform you actually realize
they can sing sing oh yeah yeah
like this is all gravy he's my favorite
one he's the most talented
he's the leader of the group oh he's
probably the one that's killing it
it's a dope song by the way hell yeah it
is that's my [ __ ] this is my [ __ ]
super kitty lyrics
so they're doing english yeah come on
dude
what wait this song's not in it so you
say
it is english a lot of the songs in
korean which
i prefer them to do yeah he's my
favorite
rap monster see this i'm like all right
these boys are getting it
see he he has the big voice here the guy
remember the guy in orange
i think he [ __ ] up you tell me chin i
don't know music and we're going to
pretend he's really sick yeah that's not
he's not see then like i don't like that
you're ready
the guy in orange remember right here
you see that yeah what is that oh
that sounded bad but it's weird because
that's like his moment and they
they're all you know his man their
manager they have to give certain ones
camera time in certain lyrics like
there's a real like
break it down like that yeah and that
when the leader who kicks off he gets
the most time
he does another one going through a
transition probably the best singer the
wait the wait who's the best singer
oh the one who's trying to yeah
transition can sing
i hate that i'm calling this dude
into a woman before our eyes i mean
every video he gets more
rap monsters which one is no rap
monster's the the no jimny
jim jim jimmy jimmy jimin
how do you say jungkook
oh jungkook v is the leader jyn [ __ ]
up at the grammys
[Laughter]
rim lost a lot of weight tonight fits
better with the group he's really thick
and j-hope struggles with his looks what
about sugar damn j-hope sugar's dope too
j-hope sugar has some hits sugar went
off on his own and did rap
oh really yeah oh he can he can actually
spit i don't know so he's like
jay boog oh he's a korean yeah he's
korean but millions and millions of
views is there
now they went oh cool you guys like our
music well here's our animate series
with the same songs
so now that it's all animation it's dope
oh damn
probably going crazy over there my son
can't get enough of it yeah yeah
that's why i know something is there a
lot of korean rappers nah hell
no so pretty much in korea like like i'm
not talking about like they
they're korean and they rap in america
because pop culture in korea yeah
definitely
it's actually booming right now jay
park's a big part of it too he's
producing a lot of these guys oh she's
bringing them up jay park's our boy jay
park
he's a korean zombie manager kind of
yeah yeah
he's associated he's a k-pop star huge
k-pop he was part of one of the biggest
ever groups in k-pop and then he left
korea
and started to do his own thing here
damn but now he's been he's killing him
he's like yeah he has his own company at
aomg he's like the should knight of
korean
hey you know what it's a korean rapper
who is korean rapper really it's a group
how do you know
cause i saw it like on twitter but trap
music comes from trap houses yeah but
i don't think korea has tried i
guarantee you that guarantee
there's a thing it does is their sound
no they're talking about traffic
rap style okay let me just play this for
you we can't put on here but this is
like us
this is jay parks dude but listen to the
song is he famous
he has a no there's like an underground
kind of dude see it's better when they
rap in korean yeah i love it
that's why there's not a lot of views on
here oh he's not in bts right no no no
no
got it i'm saying but this is like the
korean rap culture oh i bet there's
going to be this hair explode they get
they go hard i bet it's going to explode
i'm not mad at it yeah
uh korean song called it g ma that was
so
big that american rappers took that beat
and covered it so dumbfounded was on the
american version
waka flaco was on the american version
the foundation was on it too yeah the
american version but this is
uh that's the original one that was so
hard that amazing
fantasy yeah 76 million views 5 44.
the beat goes hard we're masks before
it's cool mm-hmm
yeah everyone wanted to hate on the
asian mascot
now what's up doug but this is the
beginning of that like trap music with
koreans
bro i'm about it you're gonna gush us
i [ __ ] with it oh they got grills too
yeah asians who rap are super super hip
hop
oh they don't get
that's korean alcohol they drinking over
there oh yeah damn
holding it like it's a 40 ounce i
thought that was lean i like it
i bet i bet korean hip-hop's gonna
explode it's cool how they do it like
they go
uh american to korean like they switch
it off
yeah like i like that i want to do like
i prefer them in korean
in korean but then every now and then
english words that's fine
you perform my son watch so much bts i'm
like is he going to pick it up wait
that big song my son just starts
spinning korea
so that big song dynamite do they have
it in korean too
no not not not out here oh they have a
bunch of songs in korean though
got it that's one thing that k-pop they
have not been able to do yet is they
always try to
go from being huge in korea and they try
to become american like
for the american audience to like them
but american audiences love them being
korean
you know when they try to sing english
lyrics it doesn't feel the same but you
know what's weird they have that song
with halsey where she
sings in english yeah and then they mix
english with koreans
that's that one's really good it is i
love it what's the name of it
ooh it's nice palsy and bts
do it right now john i walk in my house
right now my son did someone tell me
halsey was pregnant no yeah
yeah she was pregnant pregnant and i
love her boy with love
boy with love all right see the one with
blue hair he's the leader
they make sure you know if you paint
look at him lead her
okay i love when they their feet right
there
yeah they're big for a reason this made
me like her more when i saw her with
this
i like that they'd be doing this like oh
they can dance dude
you can watch video of them like their
dance routine
they go hard they do they spend like
hours
we should just learn one of their
routines and do it oh my god i wish you
see how
everyone has their own time yes they do
there's categories in kpop so there's
remember i said there's always like the
cute person
there's a lead singer there's a rapper
there's like a dancer yeah there's
always that
there's like which i get what you're
saying mm-hmm we can re
like recreate yeah that right there oh
he wants to do it who would you be
you're the transitioning one
no no i thought i was jm which one's jm
james the rapper
no the tall guy the guy he's the third
yeah the [ __ ]
i'm v why are you d because you can come
on i'm v
you give yourself v yeah
you're jimin
me the ellen of the group sugar no he'll
give me nothing oh sugar's hard
who's sugar sugar and v are like good
guys
if i had a pick for you i'd give you
sugar my name shouldn't be sugar but
also when you're you're women i'm v
you know why
yeah yeah we'll figure it out i'm sure
if we got with his producers
okay he's the best style too yeah where
is he holding like a terracotta
v i'll be honest hopefully if he sees
this you need to break off on your own
dude you
he's a bona fide star brother do you
think he could be a solo he's already
broke off on his own hey what do you do
yeah animosity on the group what because
you know the whole inside where are you
here i'm balls diva and bts he's harry
styles
here he has his own [ __ ] he has that
blue hair super saiyan blue there's like
a lot of stalkers and [ __ ]
he does yeah so many how old are these
guys they got to be like what
early 20s probably 20 early 20s
might be 20 might be 40. i don't know
friends are tough dude
26. oh oh they're all i was thinking
they were like 19.
hey but hey go to uh
v has his own uh [ __ ] this is listen
i know he just came out of nothing i'm
like
trying to give you try to give me the
transition
he has 6.4 million on his own
personalities
who's the two people he's following of
course the group and who else yeah
probably management
he probably doesn't run this bts and the
answer prior is that management
it's probably his management 9.3 million
no posts jam
how many does bts have followers i think
i'm pretty sure they're like
40 billion 38 million 386 see
see how they're good scroll down to
let's see this [ __ ]
during gucci who's that guy that's not v
you can't tell you know what's sugar you
know what circus that's sugar they're
all getting a lot of work done on their
faces
they are yeah there's your boy
that's the dude who messed up right no
no isn't this j-hope yeah it's hard to
tell it
yeah it's hard you're getting so much
work done yeah
look at that [ __ ] pic they look like
the beatles over there they used to be
super hated on
really yeah they [ __ ] slap slapper
they know somebody's birthday who's
who's that guy who's that talented [ __ ]
that's v that's v yeah i'm telling
youtube v on his own man
he goes hard happy birthday his lips
there
fake
i don't know who this is your page is
super different man we got to switch it
up we can't give you
no you can't yeah you gotta hurry and we
don't have a group
what i'm not joining the group we're
trying to recreate i'm not vegan
he's had a lot of work and he lost a lot
of weight because he used to be like the
thick one of the girl
rap master rap master right monster
monster monster rap monster
all right well i'll be right i guess
since we have you know similar things
you know why is this like the page like
an
ikea page why why is that it's a good it
does kind of look like
yeah that shit's lit though it's
different who's that right there who
that that's the that's the guy who um
struggles with his pronouns
oh the truth that's the one that brendan
thinks is the ugliest right no no no no
no no that's the truth
no that's not the one you'll know the
one i think i know that keeps scrolling
down
it's pretty happy he's probably the most
handsome
that guy there's the most handsome we
keep going down well the ugly dude
probably got the
ugly dude i bet they didn't make pages
for him that's that's the guy
it is but that's live doug had work done
this you gotta have an ugly one of the
group
think of destiny's child and sync
backstreet boys there weren't no ugly
girls in destiny's childhood michelle
was
bad back when there was five you have an
argument not when there was three
destiny children yeah
are you serious oh really oh really
we're gonna pretend they're all pretty
who's ugly so these two i saw where you
was going with that the hell with you
but it's not easy to point them out
because they're not beyonce or kelly
thank you michelle was beautiful she's
gorgeous
you saying they're ugly they're not ugly
okay okay
i'm telling you just that's the child
aren't that talented
yeah i would say that by you i mean all
of them but
really rolling talented why are you [ __ ]
have you heard her a dilemma with nelly
motivation oh motivation
oh yeah yeah no she's killing it name a
recent song of hers
she's
yeah that's that's messed up she's just
because she's she's not beyonce she we
know
all right she is she'll give you that
just like lance bass ain't justin
timberlake
[Applause]
that's why there's a comparison lance
bass went on to do his own [ __ ] kelly
went to go underwater you know
no i mean lance gay bass
[Laughter]
no bro you mean you know the computer i
mean
that's what that is jc never went off
and did [ __ ] he he did that oh
and then bring it on to me he had a
verse in that song with uh
black black yeah or 702 whatever that
group's name was
damn he looked horrible
why'd you choose that picture just look
at him i'm sitting here trying to defend
this man
you bring up this [ __ ] you look like
a lance bass stayed relevant
what lance bass went on to have a career
dude jake
what singing tv hosted shows he still
i didn't know last pass had had a
musical career after in sync
well he did yep well kelly rowland had a
music career after this
she had a similar critter lance because
jc make any songs after instinct
yeah yeah one single probably popped not
me what one single that popped it was
like a big hit
well okay kelly had multiple she had
multiple hits on her own
yeah yeah on her own bro bro
motivation is not our own motivation has
a feature on it
but is she's again on her own or does
she have little wayne
and these other big names with her
man hold on are we moving the goal post
right now
not at all we just said on her own it's
kelly rolling off her album
no it's kelly rowland with little wayne
and anything little wayne touches his
big
again name a kelly rowland song but
without a famous person on it go
bro go go no go chappelle wait hold on
oh you got to look it up
you gotta
yeah yeah lil wayne's fantastic okay
okay hold on let me think
give me the last best one exactly
they're the same
i can't name a lance pass song but i
know they both had careers now
in any song lance bad bass did if it had
little wayne on it
yeah of course it'd be big it's little
[ __ ] way that was a great song
yeah it was all right this song
go to [ __ ] kelly rowland's catalog
thank you give me bring it up
bring up all right yeah yeah thank you
because
it's looking rough right it's looking a
little rough i looked are you looking it
up okay
hold on wait so we're looking rough oh
it's a little rough dilemma is the
biggest one
dilemma motivation hey hold on who's on
dilemma
oh we're crazy and then who's on
motivation oh that's right little women
oh no flowers was big on her own that's
cool that just came out that's huge yeah
i didn't know i didn't have a huge song
you heard no he's being an [ __ ] no
one's ever [ __ ] heard of it
i bet flower slaps if we gave it a
chance oh keep it between us
i was big in 2011. hold on keep going i
know you go to last west get on kelly
road
yeah i know it's not looking this is for
my girls is a big slap
no lance bass yeah go to lance [ __ ]
bass
coffee coffee was it i don't think lance
has had any songs after instinct
well then you don't know [ __ ] watch look
as a solo artist he never did solo
solo artist party for awake walking on
air
dude cherish you lance bass get that
[ __ ]
actually you know that song i do now
imagine nelly on this
look at his views though the same last
pass
that's
that he still has more clout than kelly
rowland
oh
jc was the host of uh america's best
dance crew
we're just [ __ ] shaking right now i
think helly roland was too at some point
jc had a live q a on reddit man
he
but that ain't his not him though he's
like that's so weird oh my god
go to jc shazam he has catalog as an
individual i don't think
i love him i'm telling you bro y'all are
going low y'all scraping the plate right
now
blowing me up was a big one oh was it
yeah do you remember this let's hear it
okay okay at least he hasn't yeah at
least it's his song
bro hey if he had a little wayne on it'd
be funny
no he could do it on his own he's jc
you'll recognize this song
hey that's uh sarah reed this song
is [ __ ] trash
trash turn it off
you trying to wait to a good part win
bruh winchell
that was a good part right right there
you guys
missed it you cap
okay yeah hey i [ __ ] with jc's ass
1000
yeah yeah hey
jc because jc was also like it was him
and jt that were leading those vocals
in nsync
jc goes off on that track you need to
calm down
what the frustration
dude over justin timberlake i'm just
saying everyone in the world was like
everyone in the world's like if we could
just get rid of everyone but justin
timberlake
immediately look at them early videos in
nc bro justin wasn't that good
not right away not right away well if
you watch even watch the fellaini
doing the choreography they dancing and
[ __ ] i hear you just it wasn't that
tight i hear you but look the fact that
you were so close
he said you need to cocktail you gotta
calm down bro you gotta pay attention to
this [ __ ] though
he tried to force us to suck we don't
care about we just can't
care we don't care you've got them what
do i say the point is
dude you know what jc jc did better than
justin on the song was
uh this i promise you he hit yeah he hit
the notes on it better
he hits those notes justin got better
look listen he
he got better and hold on hold on and
that's what i'm saying
i'm justin 100 percent bro you can say
i'm just gonna say how could you not be
this
[Laughter]
i know he looks like the dude from his
hair was just harry
potter
he's all hanging on dude
look like peter pettigrew stupid harry
potter i'm supposed the dude he looks
like loki
i think yeah oh uh avengers yeah yeah
who avenges loki i don't know avengers
loki
remember when lance bass came out
everyone was like yeah
we knew this thank you i didn't
oh he does look like him similar here
yeah oh yeah that's a good look
yep yeah hey rock your hair chase
just watch him wake up tomorrow and his
notifications are blowing
oh
okay was saying it was trash because i
don't think he wrote it or did anything
no he's just
yeah but you also i get what you're
saying jc like carried the vocals same
thing with kelly rowland did with
beyonce a couple of songs
cater to you
she had the best verse yeah come on no
no i'm not trying to do a chappelle but
i'm stumped
their bank accounts beg to differ you
can you
listen you gotta you gotta realize this
this is the thing about brennan okay
he's a stats guy
okay he's all stats but so that's that's
why he argued that's why like
whenever he says something like oh no no
because he's a stats guy i get you you
know let's see
let's just talk about stats on that
specific song you can't tell me
kelly rowland didn't body beyonce no
never never in her life is she
on cater to you her verse was better
than beyonce who do you think gave her
that verse
[Music]
you think anything went past beyonce
without her approving all of it so
beyonce was like
you could have 100 percent wasn't her
dad the man's or some [ __ ] yeah
yes he ain't her manager no more no no
she was like
i gotta get a professional
[ __ ] performing at the grammys
you keep asking for coca-cola in the
green coca-cola
you know what this is yeah this is i'm
not about to argue no
i remember i remember [ __ ] beyonce
took the [ __ ]
off hold on tomorrow you remember when
they did cater to you
at the awards show and they gave like
all these guys like
uh terence howard lamb dances dances and
jason they did
yeah beyonce had a whole lot of good
days
oh you can't do that anymore that's when
the war shows was popping that's what
brendan is saying
when nicki minaj performed in phoenix
she gave stephen ash a laptop
yeah rihanna used to do that too she
used to bring someone on stage and like
tie them down and do like uh
oh he does what else currently does as
the backstreet boys
they give live dances yeah ooh i watched
them live in uh
london they're still killing it live
though they still tour like no they
still slap
i mean the you know some of their notes
oh
[ __ ] they're voices
listen i'll tell you i went to a
backseat boys uh concert like two years
ago
what the [ __ ] they put on the show
no they're performers
you know it was them and new kids on the
block yeah and then just
all hey new kids on the block they still
kill it they still do it and they can
hit those notes
you don't realize how talented that
what's name uh the who's the lead singer
or the new kid on black jordan knight
uh jordan knight jordan knight sing-sing
you've never seen the documentary on the
backstreet boys coming back
it's so good the little one who could
like really sing on uh
brian something brian something he's the
blonde haired one yeah him and
him carter were the two like main
singers
they had this weird relationship and
then they're they're like trying to go
over their tour dates
is it well maybe if your voice he goes
no that's called what it is
you can't sing like you used to dude
they have to leave the room they're
about to start fighting really he's like
is this in a documentary yeah he's like
i think we'd be okay if you could
[ __ ] say wait which ones
uh so the guy on the far right he lost
his voice out yeah
something damn there's like a weird
relationship there too
because nick carter started yelling at
him like i'm not your little brother you
can't bully me like
that was so weird everyone's like what
the [ __ ] is going on bro homie look like
a white snoop dogg right there
no he like j uh jared leto
white snoop
yeah uh he's always at the super bowl oh
the guy with the thing yeah the one that
has his nails painted yeah yeah
yeah with your nails for me nah nah you
what no
real about your baby like your skate
days or something
all the emotions yo black guys it's some
black ass
what your feeling is out there doing all
that
okay
[Laughter]
bro what's that rapper with the red hair
and paint his fingernails should be red
who no
rock star yes he was like where did he
get in like a cop car
black dude is he good yo please bro it's
so funny please
all right i got it i got it i got it i
got a big dude
[ __ ] hilarious i got it do i'm sure
if you uh
youtube uh hold on i gotta find this
dude it's so funny
was it the babies uh rockstar yeah
google the baby's rockstar
cover hold on living in the
cop car but he said when he say the
n-word
he's a black guy it sounds racist
bro everybody keeps tagging me in his
videos yo is this you
mario judah i swear to god dawg hey
yo so he just shows you how good the
baby is
i guess hey so he was getting he was
pressing playboy card he released his
album
so he'll just make these rants about on
his instagram page about like
playboy corny you have five seconds to
put up
i'm just gonna keep i'm like yo what the
hell you just play boy cardi was like i
don't even know you dude
go to instagram please
oh gosh it's like that skateboarder
everybody keeps tagging me in the big
dude
yeah he can skateboard though look just
look at the hold on the rent go down
dude he's the [ __ ] he's just renting
what's his name mario nah mario judah
it looks intense yes i'm saying he was
going hard on play but he's just
dude he's living his [ __ ] life that's
what he's doing i think uh oh that one
right there where he's screaming in the
middle yeah watch this
i don't even know you hold up i do not
really
flash he's dropping on christmas y'all
drop your special
somebody said hey kool-aid man
because you won't just drop your [ __ ] on
christmas like you said what else shoes
or if you don't
i will drop i think you're saying
give your fans what we want please oh
he's a fan of playboy carter yeah and
they do
playboy's like bro i don't even know you
i don't even know she would do that he's
a rapper though
good for that dude yeah bro oh my gosh
[ __ ] he was [ __ ] me look at his nails
look at the face look at everything
and when he says the n word i feel like
i was like bro you shouldn't say it
you shouldn't say it he's just a big
player oh everybody
yeah yeah but he's little brows like
this [ __ ]
oh yeah look at that
[Laughter]
oh my god these comments are [ __ ]
ruthless
the counter just says piss two days left
and it's so
bright more okay look it's your
game let me see some of his older
posters
what is wrong with your help.com promo
code
[Laughter]
hey go to the video of him choking that
dude yeah here he is with trippy red
oh yes oh i just oh he put the music
video that's his uh
oh it's his music video oh my god hey
that guy put yeah strangle white people
did he say look he said he said it like
oh this guy's [ __ ] great bro everyone
tags me in his [ __ ] videos bro hold
on i gotta send you the video he's
saying
it work and then i was like yo that's
racist
[Music]
[ __ ] with this kid
[Music]
his mascara this guy's fantastic
he's tough i don't know what to make of
it man i know
oh there he is i like how people take me
to [ __ ] meanwhile
so explain this this is one question i
got for you
when you say
[ __ ] a lot of people are [ __ ] uh
that's gotta be racist
wow
let me see this whole interview oh [ __ ]
that's just like him
it's just that close one more time
[Music]
[ __ ] a lot of people were
you're saying with the long arm
yeah we needed that yeah and he blew up
he blew up
he's got him they got to be racist yeah
he's driving a hard arm
he said people will die he was like
strangled white people [ __ ]
i love how he checked out all the ages
how do we get from justin timberlake i
don't know bro
oh this guy's great i don't hang out
with him
he's in miami he's out of miami there's
two weeks
i know hopefully dude i have to beat
this dude
look at ella right there look how you
used to be a cool dude all the way to
the right
oh that used to be him oh [ __ ] look at
that
he's like a regular cool dude the next
thing you know
whoa well yeah he's different right yeah
he's all skinniest comments are [ __ ]
funny
somebody said it's so big and they put
the cry laughing emoji
people are brutal [ __ ] that let this kid
live man he's doing it
yeah he found a niche oh [ __ ]
that n word yeah that's how i knew about
him when that interview he said
people tag me in his stuff all the time
is this you is this [ __ ]
all right
oh man oh my god
okay he's crying oh
oh my god these are definitely going to
bring down the mood i am so sorry
oh what so a teacher over in arkansas
was put on leave because she actually
made a child go into the toilet and
clean it with his hands
in efforts of having him take his [ __ ]
out
what that's going to beat the [ __ ] first
of all she's on leave
yeah they're saying that they're
currently investigating what exactly
happened
but the uh teacher actually called the
mother personally and said
uh i don't know exactly why i made him
do it but at that moment i thought it
was the right thing to do i agree with
you that that was not right
so she is on administration i'd like to
stay less my girl's on the way down
right now
mm-hmm have fun my girl's about to beat
the [ __ ] daddy
dude i'm on my way yep i'm gonna [ __ ]
down your throat
oh yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] down yourself
yeah they don't go into specifics of why
she made this child
that's kind of strong yeah that's what i
said i'll [ __ ] down your throat and
hold your nose together yeah
friends just [ __ ] sitting down
give me that stuff they gave me at the
hospital yeah give me that oh yeah
hey [ __ ] your mother [ __ ] him up
oh yeah i'll be there i'll be right back
i'll come to get my son
okay so you guys heard about the three
women who got banned from uber because
they
uh attacked a uber driver in san
francisco yeah i saw that
why they attacked them why so uh there
were three people in san francisco who
uh got picked up by an uber driver and
midway through the drive the
driver knows that one of the women the
one that's coughing right now
she wasn't wearing a mask so he said hey
can you please wear a mask i can't
continue to drive unless you
have one that's just uber rules and then
she said she started making a scene
he said you know what this is more
trouble than it's worth he tries to pull
over and tells them to get out he wants
to cancel the ride
they argue that he was dropping them off
in a very sketchy
area and so they didn't want to get out
of the car district or some [ __ ]
uh they don't say where i think they
said it was close to a highway so they
didn't want to
get off there because they didn't know
the area uh he stopped the car he
wouldn't continue to drive that's when
she starts to berate him
uh starts coughing in his face rips his
mask off she snatches his phone from the
dash
board and then there's people like
driving recklessly too like
on a highway yeah she took down on
instagram because then cops went to
their instagram
uh account and saw like driving
recklessly and uh mclaren
yeah also she did their instagram so do
they have to have those videos
or i think people have recorded it and
there are probably different accounts
that still have the video that she
posted even though
her account took it is this her hair
yeah it's coming
out
[Music]
and when this actually came out they uh
found out that once the three women got
out of the car one of them actually
pepper sprayed him
and so uh one of the first investors in
uber found out about this set up a
gofund because the
company itself was going to give him
money to clean his car
uh apologize for that type of treatment
they banned the three women but the
investor actually raised a little over
forty thousand dollars for him for his
troubles
and the girl went on instagram live
basically saying well my boyfriend told
me if anyone talks to me crazy
it's my job to like pop off and that's
what i did but that's why i take lyft
anyways
lift found out and banned her from that
dope
going girl keep going and then one of
the girls were uh arrested
for uh identity theft a few days later
oh sounds like good people yeah terrible
what would you have done
if i'm him ah that's tough because
there's cameras there's three women
there's three dudes i would literally
lock the doors and jump back and choke
all of them unconscious
but since three girls i you should like
get out man
i don't know what you do because you're
you're kind of [ __ ] if you're a bigger
dude and just
[ __ ] with you yeah i mean if
someone's hitting you yeah
it's tough right if a girl hits you it's
like
yeah it's a lose-lose situation for you
in that [ __ ] i drove them right there
okay drove them right there to my sister
house
all right okay okay oh i won't yeah
like sisters huh yeah i got three that's
an advantage you guys fight as a kid
yeah my sister used to uh my oldest
sister used to like fight so many girls
really yeah she had anger problems yeah
she kind of like she reminded me of
chappelle like back in the day like no
no offense no no
not now but i'm i'll say how you looking
nah i see my sister like she was a bad
kid like she pulled the teacher hair
oh yeah she was bad baby kid yeah is she
better now
is she way better shout out to my sister
did she still have anger issues
nah nah she actually she works she works
with kids now
louisiana i was like 10 who the hell
nobody in our family saw
the toilet well that's that's that's
just like with me like people were
shocked that i worked at a daycare
my my friends have known me for like
years they're like and she's so nice to
him and she treats somebody cool yeah
that's good i'm just saying sometimes
it's just that it's like kids to change
your life you know
just grow up you never had anger no
never yeah i'm like
okay so i saw this on instagram
yesterday a cop actually
pulled over a delivery driver because he
had outstanding warrants
this guy was in the process of
delivering a pizza the cop felt bad
and delivers the pizza himself oh [ __ ]
that'd be dope
how long has it been since you had pizza
seven weeks at least
pizza's been a minute since we like we
used to have pizza parties all the time
right
yeah cause and when we were on the road
we would find like a dope pizza spot
yeah
cause people always got them like hidden
pizza gems
ninja turtles for a minute bro we just
yeah i've had pizza in a minute good
days
you're losing weight because you came
out with your shirt off and you guys go
what's that god do baby
me and jay were like damn spell losing
weight yeah dude i'm [ __ ] ryan
slimming down
i know i say this a lot but i feel so
much [ __ ] better yeah i have to work
out before shows now like monday morning
oh dude he doesn't want me to see you
guys at the gym but yeah man
so i feel so much better yeah oh yeah
i'm gonna work on the morning with mark
the trips are so healthy now like on
tour
they're just so healthy like everything
yeah with the [ __ ] we search for bro
it's just like smoking we have to stop
at whole foods yeah we don't really eat
out too much
oh it's a complete change cleveland was
like
little tug is just not nothing like
where we were it's [ __ ] nothing
what have she got but we found it so
this was submitted by
the underscore ian hickle on instagram
he wants you to
react to aaron carter's footage of him
getting ready to
box lamar odom is his first day of uh
training camp i don't know if it's his
first day
it's probably more than i know
i guess that's it yep and that's it
i'm gonna tell you something i mean
lamar looked like [ __ ] too
much that fight's about to be a [ __ ] yo
they both gonna be tired in the second
round i want to say this in the second
round
his punches are way better than lamar
okay okay
all right but these push-ups
they're both trash
uh the d.a decided to not file charges
to that kid that was in the ballroom
the bathroom brawl the football player
yeah multiplayer mr jones good for him
you guys asked what his punishment was
enough getting beat up and then
everybody finding out all righty
well here's an update on that guys go
fund me real quick
65. that's cool 97 000 now good for him
yeah wow and it was only 20 uh 20 000.
people don't suck
yeah you know a lot i saw a lot of
people writing like why do why does
everything have to be a gofundme they're
like complaining that he's getting a
gofundme
over this i mean you can't i mean
that's that's that's yeah people yeah
this is like who [ __ ]
cares all right uh check this out this
sightseeing boat had a penguin jump in
after orcas were chasing it we just saw
them
we just saw the craziest thing you've
ever seen oh i see this
[Music]
so they're trying to eat this penguin
the music is way too positive for this
animal
i know right they're right behind them
it can be funny if they knock over those
boats i know that's the scary part
orcas are not nice the penguin's
swimming fast with the orcas hot on his
[Music]
trail
[Music]
go penguin and then
they end up getting it huh you'll see
that did not sound well
look at it's so close they
ambush him so they're like he's like hey
yep hey let me help
is this it almost did i think i got it
oh it's still going
eventually the poor penguin tried to
jump into a nearby zodiac boat
come on man
now what if we really would have knocked
that boat and there it is
saved by the boat after cruising for a
bit
adorable yeah adorable well thanks jen
how cool is that um
drew brees retired thank god
be nice if the saints could get your boy
uh i know you're talking about
wilson yeah or or deshawn watson yeah oh
[ __ ] that'd be sick
i appreciate you breeze thank you
yeah i can't as i said i appreciate them
thank you for bringing that
as a super bowl but you guys ain't
winning [ __ ] for a while now
what do you mean unless you get one of
those big names yeah we'll we'll we'll
be or we'll be relevant we still have
james weston we still have to taste him
yeah we're not gonna be right tom brady
did with him
yeah you're right she's right you're
right hey man congratulations drew brees
i love drew brees he signed with uh
nbc oh so he's gonna be uh probably like
20 million a year with them though
he's gonna be on like uh the sunday
night football [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh it's okay it's on abc or nbc sunday
okay he's also gonna do the olympics do
i read oh [ __ ] girlfriend yeah that's
great yeah
pretty cool man shout out to you yeah
his name is callum
it is interesting it is oh yeah i saw
the name
of god [ __ ] another headline
yeah got cancelled man me my brother
since we were kids thought he was creepy
oh yeah he's oh he is creepy real
aggressive
sure was trying to [ __ ] oh he was in the
space jam he was in space on one and
then removed him for a spaceship too
that's probably why he's that they're
bringing them up now all right yeah
that's why they're doing it
because otherwise i haven't thought
about it yes oh yeah
what
super aggressive remember she was always
like running from him exactly here grab
her like who where you going
yeah he's too aggressive like that yeah
even his face jam he didn't look
oh
i understand that he was still trying to
it's a basketball game in space jam and
you know they play against the monsters
he's on there still trying to [ __ ] yeah
oh he is look at him there
where you going she like helped yeah he
was a little too aggressive
yeah i get it but that's i mean that's
looney tunes for you
yeah but it's john 21 yeah pepe le pew
yeah get him up out of here racist ass
uh bird though i said come here boy
man that racist the rooster yeah
come here boyfriend rooster's name
rooster from looney tunes
his uh uh origin story is
racist it is yeah man
chicken hawk what what chicken hulk nah
[ __ ] what are you talking about
no um his name's falcon yeah foghorn but
his uh
his boy is chicken hulk oh the little
one the little one yeah
this one here there yeah that's a
sidekick
okay yeah yeah i know i never heard a
chicken hawk
yeah that's his homie as i said i said
come here boy that's what he says
i like elmer's foot that wabbit yeah
fudge
yeah oh i didn't know that
all right all right shout out to foghorn
uh that's it spokane this coming week
thursday my birthday we added a late
show
all shows are sold out except for the
added shows this thursday night
and then saturday early show at 4 p.m
spokane washington
spokane comedy club this thursday friday
saturday take it to
fatkz.com then next week
this crew will be in florida miami
florida march 25th
through the 27th at the miami improv
thickboy.com is restocking the varsity
jackets the lemon jackets and the
hoodies since we sold out
those will be restocked this week and a
special st patrick's day
uh sale as well so stay tuned at
thickboy.com
is that it kids yep that's great grand
stop thank you
back then they didn't want me now i'm
not they all on me
royal toads man these swans man fresh
fresh shout out to suplex for these man
you go hard hard body you know what i'm
saying
i spin around like that because that's
where it says
brand new lamborghini
i got the weather spoons on you know me
customized from
herb juice rolly boy with the stickers
shout out to them yeah and they fit
anything
i heard that i heard that they fit
something to do
something three shows one day this
cake to wear see my
fours what the f's let's see how they're
different
see the difference
see the difference
you